we are told today that our nation is
hopelessly divided but I found something
different as I travel this country there
is another candidate that is still
running and is still running as an
anti-de State
guy uh and who does have some momentum
and in this case I am talking about
Robert F Kennedy Jr he put out a video
you're going to have to bear with us
here it's a couple minutes long but we
we discussed whether we were going to
edit it down for this I think it's worth
watching the whole thing and I just want
you to listen to the messaging because
right now what I'm sensing is that
Trump's messaging is it's it's me I'm
back you all love me let's do it again
like that there isn't necessarily we're
going to fix any of this or my behavior
will be different or anything else uh
that's one version of it and now I want
to listen to another another version of
a vision right and listen to RFK and his
vision right
here this is a day of
affirmation a celebration of
Liberty we stand here in the name of
Freedom we are committed to peaceful and
nonviolent chain we must recognize the
full human
equality of all of our people not just
to those of a particular religion not
just to those of a particular race not
just to the
wealthy but to all of the
people we must do it with a single and
fundamental
reason that it is the right thing to
do a new twist this morning for the
country's most famous political
Dynasty that it's time toal a divided
nation and return the power to the
people Robert Kennedy
J
we are told today that our nation is
hopelessly divided but I found something
different as I travel this country I
have witnessed an upwelling of optimism
that I've never seen before something is
stirring in us that says it doesn't have
to be this way and so I've come here
today to declare our independence from
the tyranny of corruption which robs us
of affordable lives our belief in the
future and our respect for each other
but to do that I must first declare my
own
independence independence from the
Democratic
party and from all other political
parties
I haven't made this decision lightly
it's very painful for me to let go of
the party of my uncles my father my
grandfather and both of my
great-grandfathers but my sacrifice is
nothing compared to the risk our
founding fathers took when they signed
the Declaration of Independence 247
years ago they knew that if their
Revolution failed every last one of them
would be hanged they chose to place
everything on the line when John Adams
put his pen down after adding his
signature to the Declaration he turned
to those present and he said to them
sink or swim live or die survive or
perish from this day on I am with my
country I'm going to make that same
pledge to you today so that I can stand
before you you as every leader should
stand before you free of partisan
Allegiance free from the back room deals
servant only to my conscience to my
Creator and to
you every president enters office
promising to unite the nation and to
work with people from the other party
across the aisle none of them ever does
it they can't they're already chosen
aside well I'm not going to have that
problem I'm going to build coalitions
from both sides of the
aisle and except for the small minority
of public officials who are actually
corrupt I'm going to tell you this
secret they too want Liberation from the
system that has captured them and isn't
that ultimately what we all want
Liberation from A system that robs us of
our wealth our health our hope our
patriotism our ideals our freedoms and
ultimately our sense of ourselves as a
good and capable
people is healing our divided nation
possible let's go take back our country
God bless you and God bless the United
States of
America I declare my Independence I
declare my dependence I declare my
Independence we declare our independence
I declare my Independence we declare our
independence I declare my Independence
we declare our independence I declare my
Independence I declare my
Independence deare me Independence we
declare our independence I declare my
Independence I declare my Independence I
declare my
[Applause]
inde
few men are willing to Brave the
disapproval of their fellows the censure
of their colleagues the wrath of their
society moral courage is a rarer
commodity than bravery in battle or
great intelligence it is the one
essential vital
quality for those who seek to change the
world I'm Robert F Kennedy Jr and I
approve this
[Applause]
message okay thanks for bearing with us
on that I hope you I hope you felt what
I felt while watching it now I just want
to get in before any of you who are
probably watching that going what wait a
minute Dave said that he would support
Trump if the STIs was out and now he's
playing a video by RFK and why am I
talking like this I am just trying to
show you that there is a vision out
there that is also good and what I want
to push Trump towards if he is the
presumptive nominee now he is the
presumptive nominee now what I want to
push him towards is a a vision that is a
little bit closer to that not just I'm
back and I'm you love me right like and
not and I'm going to get all the people
to bow to me and wave to me and tell me
I'm the greatest but something that is
truly American right to link it to the
Bill Mar I want Trump to sort of start
being intolerant of the that he
will be surrounded by because that is
the only way that we are going to fix
this thing and RFK does have by the way
a chance here he does actually have a
chance because we know that only about
30% of Republicans really love Trump
it's hard to to know what percentage of
Democrats really love Biden but it's
probably around 30% then you get all
these people who kind of you know pinch
their nose and vote for these guys uh
but if you had a viable thirdparty
candidate who was actually on all the
ballots and everything else you only
need about a third of the people to like
you and he's polling already around 25%
I'm not saying he's going to be
president I have more disagreements
politically with RFK than I do with TR
I'm just saying I think this is a moment
this is a moment now where we can sort
of push all of these guys Donald Trump
in particular to be a little bit
better